what we created here may be unique and
all human existence
all the way to God we created paradise
who are doing out here so incredible
kids are amazing
it was slow mom needs to be in the
hospital right now
now she gone
my family
this is your fault Leslie had a disease
wherever you are Stan you're sure I will
have you arrested
we can't go to mommy's funeral do what
we're told we want to see mom grandma
can't repress us sela right now this is
your first real test remember your
training they have hot dogs
what's cola poison water
so happy that I found there yes together
all local and organic how did you kill
those chickens with an axe fair night my
dad saw rotisserie chicken so you buy it
I'm it's already dead kissed each truck
you need to go to a real school I
sincerely hope young men demand I think
you've been doing your daughter has
taught me many things just now will you
be my wife stay but this comes out of a
book I don't know anything even if they
make it through whatever it is you're
doing to them they're gonna be totally
unprepared for the real world and I
happen to think the opposite is true
it's child abuse it almost handy if I
wanted to hit you I would have hit you
Abbey and I have decided that we're
gonna file for custody of the children
when I take us away from you that's
possibility our children shall be
philosopher kings makes me sell and
describe what we had